>> Jesse: CRIME IS A DISEASE AND
LIKE ANY VIRUS IT ATTACKS AN
AREA OF WEAKNESS.
LIKE YOU GET SICK EXHAUSTED AND
RUN DOWN.
CRIME FLOURISHES IN AREAS.
CHAOS RUN RAMPANT FOR DECADES.
1970s AND 80'S THINGS WERE SO
BAD IN NEW YORK THE CITY WAS
CALLED THE KILLING FIELDS.
>> JUST IMAGINE WORLD WAR II
BOMBED OUT BERLIN.
>> IT WAS JUST A WAR ZONE ARSON
MURDER RAPE BURGLARY ROBBERY.
>> IT'S CONSIDERED THE MURDER
CAPITAL OF THE UNITED STATES.
THE WORST GHETTO IN ALL OF THE
UNITED STATES.
>> AFTER DECADES OF TERROR IN
THE BIG APPLE, RUDY GIULIANI
RODE IN LIKE A WHITE KNIGHT AND
TOOK CARE OF BUSINESS.
HE MADE LIFE BETTER FOR HIS
RESIDENTS AND CLEANED UP THE
STREETS.
GUESS WHAT?
IT WORKED.
HE TACKLED CRIME AND LAID OUT
THE BIG CITY BLUEPRINT FOR
SAFETY.
ENFORCE YOUR LAWS, KEEP
CRIMINALS IN LINE.
AND ABOVE ALL, SUPPORT YOUR
POLICE.
>> SEEMS LIKE AN EASY RECIPE FOR
SUCCESS, RIGHT?
YET, SOMEHOW, 30 YEARS LATER,
EVERY DEMOCRATIC BIG RUN CITY
HAS SCREWED THIS UP.
THE LEFT HAS WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO DEFUND POLICE AND PUT
CRIMINALS BACK ON THE STREETS.
STUPID IDEAS LIKE ELIMINATING
CASH BAIL HAVE PUT US ALL AT
RISK.
YOU ARE OFFICIALLY ON YOUR OWN.
NOWHERE IS THAT MORE EVIDENT
THAN LORI LIGHTFOOT'S CHICAGO.
THE SAME LADY WHO TRIED TO CUT
HER POLICE BUDGET BY $50 MILLION
TWO YEARS AGO HAS SEEN A NEARLY
40% JUMP IN CRIME IN THE LAST 12
MONTHS.
THINGS ARE SO BAD EVEN THE BEARS
ARE BAILING ON CHICAGO AND
RUNNING TO THE SUBURBS.
YOU WANT TO GO SHOPPING IN THE
WINDY CITY.
YOU MIGHT BE RISKING YOUR LIFE.
CHECK OUT THIS VIDEO FROM LAST
WEEK WHERE ONE MAN WAS SUCKER
PUNCHED WHILE JUST STANDING
THERE AT THE STORE COUNTER.
THEY DIDN'T TAKE LONG FOR THINGS
TO ESCALATE AS HE PULLED OUT A
GUN AND OPENED FIRE KILLING THE
19-YEAR-OLD MAN WHO STARTED THE
FIGHT.
BOOM.
SO, WHAT IS CHICAGO'S ANSWER TO
THIS CHAOS?
MORE COPS?
FOR FUNDING?
NO.
IT'S GETTING RID OF CASH BAIL
BECAUSE THAT MAKES SENSE.
AND THESE PROBLEMS MIGHT START
IN THE CITY BUT IT DOESN'T TAKE
LONG UNTIL IT SPREADS TO THE
SUBURBS.
LISTEN TO THE MAYOR OF THIS
CHICAGO SUBURB TELL US WHAT IS
COMING.
>> AS OF JANUARY 1st, 2023,
THE FOLLOWING THINGS WILL GO
INTO EFFECT AND PEOPLE NEED TO
BE AWARE OF THIS.
IT ABOLISHES CASH BAIL FOR
ALMOST EVERY OFFENSE.
THIS INCLUDES BUT ISN'T LIMITED
TO KIDNAPPING, ARMED ROBBERY,
SECOND DEGREE MURDER, DRUG
INDUCED HOMICIDE.
AGGRAVATED DUI.
THREATENING A PUBLIC OFFICIAL
AND AGGRAVATED FLEEING AND
ALLUDING.
OFFENDERS RELEASED ON ELECTRONIC
MONITORING HAVE TO BE IN
VIOLATION FOR 48 HOURS BEFORE
LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN ACT.
THEY CAN ALMOST DRIVE TO ALASKA
BEFORE WE CAN EVEN LOOK FOR
THEM.
IT DENIES VICTIMS THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS AND KEEP
THIS IN MIND, BUSINESSES AND
HOMEOWNERS, OFFICERS WILL NO
LONGER REMOVE TRESPASSERS FROM
YOUR RESIDENCE OR YOUR
BUSINESSES.
SOMEONE COULD DECIDE TO LIVE IN
YOUR SHED AND ALL WE CAN DO IS
GIVE THEM A TICKET.
YOU HAVE TO DECIDE WHAT LEVEL OF
FORCE IS REQUIRED TO REMOVE
THEM.
AND WHETHER OR NOT IT'S LEGAL.
THIS IS A MASSIVE THREAT TO THE
RESIDENTS OF PARK, COOK COUNTY
AND ILLINOIS.
>> Jesse: LET ME GET THIS
STRAIGHT CAN YOU KIDNAP MY KID
BEFORE LUNCH AND BE HOME BY
DINNER?
WHAT THE HELL IS THAT?
AND WHAT'S THE POINT OF ANKLE
BRACELETS IF POLICE CAN'T CATCH
YOU UNTIL YOU ARE IN ALASKA?
WHY EVEN HAVE A GOVERNMENT IF IT
TAKES THE SIDE OF THE BAD GUYS?
BECAUSE THIS ISN'T JUST A WINDY
CITY PROBLEM.
THIS IS GOING TO BE IN YOUR
BACKYARD SOON.
WE ARE ALREADY SEEING THIS PLAY
OUT IN TENNESSEE ON WEDNESDAY, A
MANIAC LIVE STREAMED A SHOOTING
SPREE ACROSS THE WHOLE CITY
KILLING FOUR AND INJURING THREE.
BUT THIS LUNATIC SHOULDN'T HAVE
EVEN BEEN ON THE STREETS.
HE WAS CHARGED WITH ATTEMPTED
FIRST DEGREE MURDER JUST TWO
YEARS AGO.
YET, THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY AT
THE TIME, AMY WIRE RICH, THE
JUDGE, GLEN WRIGHT SIGNED OFF
SOFT PLEA DEAL.
WHAT MESSAGE DO YOU THINK THAT
SENDS OTHER CRIMINALS ACROSS THE
CITY?
THEY LOOK AT THAT AND SAY I CAN
GET RID OF ANYTHING.
ONLY TOOK ONE DAY.
>> WHITE PEOPLE HATE BLACK
PEOPLE.
>> [BLEEP]
>> [INAUDIBLE] SHOT -- WHITE OLD
LADY.
>> Jesse: HOW MUCH MORE CAN
MEMPHIS TAKE IN THE CITY WAS
ALREADY REELING FROM KIDNAP AND
MURDER OF A LOCAL TEACHER.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED.
THEY NEED THEIR GOVERNMENT TO DO
SOMETHING.
THIS LOCAL REPORTER SUMMED UP
WHAT PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE IS
FEELING.
>> THIS IS NOT A JOKE.
THIS IS EXTREMELY DANGEROUS
SITUATION AND I KNOW --
[SIGH]
MEMPHIS IS TIRED RIGHT NOW.
YEAH.
I'M GOOD.
I'M WITH YOU ALL.
MEMPHIS IS TIRED RIGHT NOW.
BEAR WITH ME.
IT'S A VERY NERVE-RACKING NIGHT.
IT HAS BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT
WEEK.
>> Jesse: THE PEOPLE ARE
LITERALLY CRYING OUT FOR HELP.
BUT THE GOVERNMENT IS NOT DOING
ANYTHING.
THE GOVERNMENT IS ACTUALLY DOING
LESS.
IN WASHINGTON, D.C. CROOKS ARE
CLIMBING UP ON TREES AND
TELEPHONE LINES TO AVOID ARRESTS
LIKE THIS IS SOME KIND OF GAME.
I MEAN, THEY USED TO GET CALLS
FOR GETTING CATS OUT OF THE
TREE.
NOW LOOK AT THIS.
AND SUSPECTS AREN'T JUST RUNNING
FROM THE POLICE, THEY ARE
RUNNING AT POLICE.
THIS GUY IN ARIZONA JUST ROBBED
A GAS STATION AND THEN RAN AT AN
OFFICER WITH A SCREWDRIVER.
>> DROP THE SCREWDRIVER.
>> NO.
>> DROP IT.
>> STOP.
[GUNFIRE]
>> THE MAN IS OBVIOUSLY MENTALLY
ILL.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE GIVE THE
GOVERNMENT TO HELP PEOPLE LIKE
THAT?
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TOOK IN
MORE TAX REVENUE THAN THEY EVER
HAVE IN THE HISTORY OF AMERICA
LAST YEAR, WHERE IS THE MONEY
GOING?
THE DEMOCRATS ARE ALWAYS SAYING
THE GOVERNMENT IS THERE TO HELP
PEOPLE.
WHY AREN'T THEY HELPING ANYBODY?
ALL THESE PEOPLE WHO NEED HELP?
AND SAN FRANCISCO IS THE WORST.
THERE IS A FAMOUS SONG THAT GOES
IF YOU ARE GOING TO SAN
FRANCISCO WEAR FLOWERS IN YOUR
HAIR.
I'M NOT GOING TO SING IT LIKE
THAT.
FORGET THE FLOWERS, WEAR A SUIT
OF ARMOR.
LOOK AT THIS SCENE ON THE
STREETS.
[DOGS BARKING]
[SHOUTING]
>> Jesse: THE ONLY THING MISSING
IS THE FLAMING GARBAGE CAN.
HONESTLY I WOULD RATHER BE IN
UKRAINE.
UKRAINE LOOKS SAFER THAN THAT
MAYBE BIDEN WHILE IS HE SAVING
UKRAINE CAN SAVE SAN FRANCISCO.
BY THE WAY, WHO IS IN CHARGE OF
SAN FRANCISCO?
GAVIN NEWSOM, NANCY PELOSI?
HOW DOES THE MEDIA LET HIM GET
AWAY WITH SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
WHY DOESN'T A REPORTER TAKE
THEIR PHONE AND PUT THIS FOOTAGE
IN NANCY'S FACE AND SAY NANCY,
THIS IS YOUR CITY.
WHAT ARE WE DOING ABOUT THIS?
THAT WILL NEVER HAPPEN BECAUSE
REPORTERS DON'T WANT ACTION.
THEY WANT ACCESS.
THESE POLITICIANS DON'T CARE
ABOUT THEIR PEOPLE.
WE CANNOT RELY ON THE GOVERNMENT
ANYMORE FOR ANYTHING.
SO I'M NOT GOING TO WASTE MY
TIME TELLING THESE OFFICIALS
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO ANYMORE.
WE HAVE TO ADDRESS THE OTHER
HALF OF THE PROBLEM.
SO TONIGHT, I'M GOING TO TALK
DIRECTLY TO THE HOMELESS DRUG
ADDICTS AND EX-CONS.
YOU ARE BETTER THAN.
THIS PICK YOURSELF UP AND PAY
ATTENTION.
HERE'S THE PLAN OF ACTION.
GET A MOTEL ROOM FOR AN HOUR AND
TAKE A SHOWER.
THEN SHAVE YOUR FACE.
WALK TO THE THRIFT SHOP, BUY
CLEAN CLOTHES.
GET SOME NEW SHOES.
THEN YOU GO TO THE BARBERSHOP
AND YOU GET YOUR HAIR CUT.
YOU STARE IN THAT MIRROR CURING
THE HAIR CUT.
YOUR FACE IS CLEAN.
YOU SMELL CLEAN.
YOU GOT A NEW SHIRT.
LOOK UNDER YOUR OWN EYES IN THE
MIRROR.
SEE OF THE REAL YOU AND SAY TO
YOURSELF THIS IS WHO I AM.
THEN YOU HOP ON A BUS AND GET AS
FAR AS AWAY FROM YOUR SLEAZY
CREW AS FAR AS POSSIBLE.
GO BACK TO YOUR FAMILY OR IF YOU
CAN'T, GET OUTSIDE OF THAT CITY
WHERE THERE IS NOT A DEALER ON
EVERY BLOCK AND GET YOURSELF A
JOB, ANY JOB.
BECAUSE A JOB GIVES YOU PURPOSE.
TAKE A BROOM, AN APRON, A LAWN
MOW ARE, I DON'T CARE.
DO WHAT YOU HAVE GOT TO DO.
WORK ALL DAY AND SAVE MONEY.
SAVE 10% OF YOUR PAYCHECK.
PUT IT AWAY.
AND THEN DRINK A LOT OF WATER.
DO SOME PUSHUPS, GO FOR A WALK,
FIND A BOOK, READ, SLEEP ALL
NIGHT AND WORK ALL DAY.
IT'S THAT SIMPLE.
LISTEN TO YOUR CONSCIENCE.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S RIGHT AND WHAT'S
WRONG.
LIVE IN THE MOMENT.
AND EVERY MOMENT IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A DECISION.
WHO DO YOU WANT TO BE?
YOU WANT TO BE BETTER.
AND THAT'S HOW YOU GET A FRESH
START.
YOUR LIFE WILL CHANGE IF YOU DO
TH